こんちゃー肇社長です今日の夜ご飯でございます
たまにはねこういうのミリでただお金夜ご飯食べるものをそうなんでわけにはいかない
んだ
行くけど8朝日ちょっとちんたら素材神谷さんと国一
前面に買って皆さんプレゼン種類はあります
うん那須入っている
最悪ははいこちらが一応全メニューでございますこれでをちゃんと店員さんに電話で
全部にくださっていったからね入ってないのがあったら俺のせいじゃないよとりあえず
2を全部開けていきます
配球でこちらが全面的になりますこの辺ががフライ系等いけ
ピザ別アップ the bay
[音楽]
ブーブー便 nule だけ持ったんですけどこれ見解です
第六ねもうカレーじゃないネットショッピングでもちろんかね
のトッピングみたいなだけで全然まだなトッピングが待ってるんですけどちょっとも
載せれないんでも食べませいただきますまずはポテトサラずうから高ま
[音楽]
甘い再購入前くるねフライ系もね美味しい車
うん甘い恋じゃあチョッピングの美味しいんだよねこんなんじゃトマトソースか
うーん今回は子ですありがとうございます中宮寺ずっぷみたいですか
まあ山じゃあお前ラン3社は今回は池から
[音楽]
おっ
いわゆる車何でも列も食えないんだよ
[音楽]
&阻止来るために来て山い
いーんず故障だ言ってよいいよえっとつい不覚にもまた食べなかった
俺いつもそうだ
いつも一人誰通ってすっ
一匹食べれないってパターンが
保護級アルバがしろって言っただけ
[音楽]
ザーン
nume
me
ani
やばい室
あえてん
金住に食ってみたみたいな動画づらくという
かで前面に食ってる時の回は見てる動画ですよ
この5分だけですね新しくない新しい本当に全部食ったのかっていう憶測からた
突っ立つことから始まり今もうこの終盤だけど実はすごいきついよみたいなことを身に
伝わるから
すっげークリエイティブな道だと思うわけ
ここここをの国でお盆やする出走で全部食い終わらないところで終わるっていう
そういうの出すたらさぁみんなは画期的過ぎて
ついてこれだからああ
me
voodoo
ちょっとおっ
出すとそれだけでなぜ上ねぇんだーって思うかもしれないんですけどまずもう限界です
遅いな展開じゃない
本当に申し上げ掛けるかなそうだね実は昨日の夜から初めて朝に
ってありませんが地獄がパサの厨二と話す
だけで男二人でも多分全メニューはかなりキツイものがありますか
ぜひ皆さん
試さないといけません
小さいん
[音楽]
nd
uh